the result that I hope to show you or
give you an intuition for in this video
is something that we will use in a in
the proof of the chain rule or an a
proof of the chain rule actually mean we
may do more than one proof of the chain
rule but the result we're gonna look at
is if we have some function U which is a
function of X and we know that it is
continuous it is continuous at x equals
C so if we know this then that's going
to imply that the change in U goes to
zero as our change in X in this region
around C goes to zero this is what I
want to get an intuition for that a few
is continuous at C then as our change in
X around C gets smaller or it gets
smaller and smaller suarez approaches
zero then our change in U approaches
zero as well so let's just to think
about this and already even kind of
prove it to ourselves a little bit more
rigorously let's think about what it
means to be continuous at X equal C well
the definition of continuity is so this
literally is the same thing as saying
that the limit as X approaches C of U of
X is equal to U of C that the the limit
the limit that our function approaches
is X approaches C is equal to the value
of the function at C we don't have a a
point discontinuity or a jump
discontinuity if we had a jump
discontinuity then then the limit
wouldn't exist and we've seen that in
previous videos now I'm just gonna
manipulate this algebraically so it
essentially gives us this conclusion
right over here so this we can rewrite
it's important to realize that U of C
this is just going to be some value
it looks like I've kind of you know
maybe this is a function of X or
something but no this is this is just
going to be some value I've inputted C
here and I've evaluated the function
that and so there's gonna be some number
it could be 5 or 7 or PI or negative 1
it's but it's just going to be some
value some constant so I can treat it
like a constant so this is going to be
the same thing as saying the limit
as X approaches C of U of X minus U of C
is equal to is equal to zero and
actually in the video where we prove
that differentiability implies
continuity we started with this and we
and we proved that right over there we
show that these two are equivalent
things but hopefully you can even think
about the intuition this is just if the
limit is U of X approaches the limit of
U of X as X approaches C is equal to
this then when you evaluate this limit
the limit as X approaches C well this
thing is going to approach U of C
because we saw it right up here U of C
minus U of C is indeed going to be equal
to zero so hopefully you don't feel like
it's too much of a stretch and you can
just subtract U of C from both sides and
apply properties of limits and you can
get this result as well but this is
interesting because this essentially can
take us to this that the idea that as
our change in X gets smaller and smaller
and smaller as it approaches zero then
our change in our function is also going
to approach zero now let's just look at
a go let's just graph this or visualize
this to get a sense of that so this is
our x-axis whoops that's our x-axis
let's call that ru ru access maybe and I
did you intentionally because that's the
variable we'll use in our proof of the
chain rule video and let's say this
right over here is our function let's
say this right over here that is C this
right over here is U of C U of C and
then let's just take some arbitrary x
over here so some arbitrary X and then
this right over here this right over
here is U of X is U of X so if we define
if we define our change if we define let
me do this if we define our change in
our change in U is equal to U of X minus
U of C which makes sense because this is
our change
in you so let's say this is going to be
U of X minus U of C and if we define our
change in X is equal to X minus C which
is in this case it is X minus C it is X
minus C then we can rewrite this limit
right over here instead of saying the
limit as X approaches C we could write
the limit as Delta X approaches 0
because if X approaches C then Delta X
is going to approach 0 so we could write
this the limit as Delta X approaches 0
of Delta U of Delta U is going to be
equal to 0 this we define this as our
change in U and it is our change in U so
this is equal to 0 so another way of
thinking about this is as Delta X
approaches 0 our change in U our change
in the function is going to approach 0
so as as Delta X approaches 0 as Delta X
approaches 0 Delta u approaches 0 and
that's what we wrote over here Delta U
approaches 0 as Delta X approaches 0 and
a lot of ways this is hopefully a common
sense we're dealing with a continuous
function as you get smaller and smaller
and you could just think of it this way
as you get smaller and smaller changes
in X's as our change in X gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller
well because it's continuous you
wouldn't be able to say this for a
discontinuous function but because it's
continuous or you wouldnt be able to say
this for for some just can use
discontinuous functions as our change in
X gets smaller and smaller and smaller
then our change in U is going to get
smaller and smaller and smaller so it
makes intuitive sense but hopefully this
makes you feel even better about it
because we're going to use this idea to
prove the chain rule in the next video